uh
how are you doing okay my first virtual
press
press jacket so i'm doing i'm doing all
right man i'm doing oh i've been doing
this since march this is old hat
nice nice you know um so let me start by
saying i've seen
nine of the ten episodes of season five
and it is spectacular i
absolutely loved this season um thank
you so much steven appreciate that
did you notice okay i have to ask so you
obviously this is the fifth season of
the show
did you notice when you were getting
these scripts that like the
size and scale of this season was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
well we had certainly discussed it
beforehand i mean you know i
as you know i was i was a fan of the
books before i knew it was being adapted
and
book five was one of my favorites i knew
it was coming
and um there's so much payoff the stuff
that has been kind of cooking for the
last
couple of years um you know when when
lorraine and ty and daniel
and the writing team started discussing
with us what the plan
was um we we knew
that the potential for for what we could
pull off if we hit it
uh would be really great and um i
i'm i'm so proud of this season i think
it's our best yet and
um i'm excited for the fans to see it i
i i don't think the fans are prepared
for how good this is gonna be
i'm so glad i i
i'm just i can't say enough how much i
love the season
um the thing about this season is that
uh and this is spoiler free obviously
is that you know this has been building
up the last four years have
paved what you are getting in this
season and
everyone is separated in a way that is
not
hasn't been done before um can you sort
of talk about how everyone is on these
individual paths
yes yes the structure is very different
um
and it because the structure is
different it also is kind of
when the events happen it's a little
disconcerting you know having been
familiar with the story a certain way
for so long
um you know i mean for holden he arrives
in the beginning of season
five more confident than he's ever been
in his leadership skills so to speak his
feet are firmly on the floor but his
family scatters out into the
into the system um and then all of these
events occur
you know and suddenly the culmination of
what you were saying of all of these
things that have been building for so
long
uh come to the fore really dramatically
um and they're alone you know all of
these
all these characters that we've seen uh
go through these things with each other
are alone and it's a very different kind
of tone and there's a kaleidoscope of
different ones
um so the feel of it is very different
and i think it speaks to the confidence
in the writing
you know we always we've always been
blessed with great writing on this show
but
um but to have you know such a dramatic
creative risk
taken in the fifth season of something
successful is very rare
and um that that really is just it just
speaks to noreen and ty and daniel and
um and their leadership and guiding the
story through
um i think the fans are really gonna dig
it besides your own storyline which
obviously doesn't count
which of the other storylines this
season
were you like wow that is really good
yeah i think
um my favorites and the ones i've been
looking forward to seeing
as a fan of the books was amos in
baltimore
and naomi going after philip i think um
those two story lines were
some were some of some of the moments
that
having read them so long ago i was
really waiting
to see how they would be done um and to
kind of explore
the past of these characters that we
really haven't
um we've seen hints of but we really
haven't you know explored
as much as as i think everyone would
like to have seen
uh it's got that you know that suspense
of that and the payoff is really big
and then also seeing um drummer you know
drummer's storyline
uh of what happens with her actual
inactions of seasons past and and what
the consequences of that are
uh and we get to see a very different
kind of social dynamic than we've seen
as well you know
there's a very very different domestic
dynamics we see from these folks
and different sides of these characters
that we haven't seen
so um i would say that those three were
the ones that
um that i was looking forward to seeing
and they they all crushed it
obviously i mean they're all so talented
100
i could devote the next 20 minutes of
talking about them but
i'm gonna switch to something else um i
am both i'm super bummed that season six
is going to be the last season uh
on amazon but yet i'm so thankful to
amazon for saving the series
and allowing you guys to know okay
season six is going to be the last one
um for you what does it mean to have
this sort of
chapter like closing if you will um
and what can you tease when do you start
filming
well i will say that i'm grateful for it
too
you know i've i've done this long enough
to know how rare it is to have the
ability to tell a story
uh on your own terms beginning middle
amendment that is very very rare to have
and it's this story has been so
important to everyone involved we've
really given it everything
uh to try and make it the best that it
can be um
and to know that we have the ability to
close it our way
um i'm deeply grateful for deeply deeply
grateful
and um you know the end of season six is
um and the end of book six is a
satisfying
place to stop so i'm deeply grateful for
that and as
as for me you know this this whole
journey has been
um you know the greatest creative
experience i've ever had i mean i've
you know um i've been doing this a while
even though i'm young i was in the union
i think 2001.
um and this is the first project i've
ever been behind the camera on
um and i've learned so much and uh it's
a story that i've cared about deeply for
for the entire run of the show and um
i'm incredibly proud of it i'm
incredibly proud that um that we're
going to be able to finish this story
the right way
sure now let's let's ask the i'm going
to ask you again when do you
when does it start filming what can you
tease oh yeah so the beginning
of next year the beginning of next year
is when we start but i i
i can't go into exact dates um but it's
the beginning of next year so
um you know book book five and six is
kind of one movement if people are
kind of out there um you know obviously
we deviate a little bit
um through the guidance of the authors
uh within our writer's room
and executive producing but um i'm
excited to
to get into it um you know if they like
season five they'll love season six as
well
sure what how long does it actually take
to film a season
and has it changed at all over the five
seasons like when you're making it at
sci-fi with say four months at amazon
it's been six months sure well it
depends you know the episodic wars have
changed over the years
um but it's roughly it's roughly between
six and seven and a half months
depending on what they have been over
the years i mean
um you know our shooting style didn't
change really
that much i mean we always try to
improve the structure of how we do
things
um but we always even you know from the
beginning shot it
assuming that it would be streamed so um
you know it's it's a it's about a half a
year shooting and then we spend the next
half of the year doing post
so it's a it's a full-time full year
uh commitment you know especially with a
show like this with so much the effects
and
whatnot um post is a long long process
and they do beautiful work i mean you
know the
effects are spectacular so yeah it's a
it's a it's a complete year it's a
complete year of work
got it um again i just want to say
congrats on season five
it is fantastic and i hope to speak to
you again
um i guess in a year
or or sooner but seriously congrats
people are going to love this season
thank you so much appreciate it good
seeing